so maybe you're studying or you're doing
your phds and you're feeling really
overwhelmed and a little bit burned out
and you click on this video to help to
get some tips so in this video I want to
try to give you these tips and this is
mainly based on personal experience
because I've definitely noticed how your
PhD and how your studies can creep into
your personal life and kind of take over
everything that you're doing so this
video is mainly made for me a little bit
in the past and hopefully it can help
you out as well so one of the first
things that I have as a rule that I kind
of apply now almost always is to not
work at home between markets too much
because I do still work at home
sometimes but I've definitely noticed
that through Corona because I did the
first two years of my PhD during Corona
and I worked at home almost always like
everyone else and this kind of created
that but that my personal life and my
studying slash work life these lines
became really really blurred and I've
definitely noticed all the downsides of
not having a clear separation between
your work and your personal life so
first of all when I work at home all day
even though I'm sometimes a little bit
more productive because I don't see my
colleagues at all I definitely feel or
felt quite isolated on the days that I
worked at home and also something that
I've noticed because if you're working
at home you usually really have to rely
on your own willpower and your own
personal motivation not to get
distracted but I don't know about you
guys but at home I have definitely a
thousand other things that I would or
could do that are not my PhD and I've
noticed that I would often get
distracted at home spend some time
cleaning spending some time eating
spending some time calling a friend and
then before I know it an hour went by
and I did nothing and during Corona I
just was super super strict to myself
really being like you can only work you
cannot do anything else during the hours
that you have to work but I think what's
way easier is just not to work at home
so now that we don't have to work at
home I just rather go to for example
University or to the library and do all
of my work there so the second thing
that for me became really really
important is exercise and thinking about
your General Health and I know everyone
says this you have to exercise and blah
blah blah but I've definitely noticed it
over the last three months I had a
deadline that I was pushing towards and
I was kind of neglecting all of my
exercise routines or everything that I
did outside and to be honest my back
just started hurting I started getting
really really tired and also I just had
this General brain fog that I couldn't
get rid of and if you're one of those
people that really despises exercise I I
think even taking a long walk in the
evening or being outside or for example
a little bit of yoga can already have
the same benefits as having a full
strenuous exercise routine so something
that really worked for me is that I
truly enjoy dancing and doing yoga so I
try to every day during the week do
these two a little bit and then in the
weekend I really make time for these
Hobbies so I really try in the weekend
to do a class for example at the gym and
doing this I noticed that in general I'm
way less agitated I'm better able to
focus during the hours that I have to
focus but also to truly relax during the
hours that I have to relax so number
three and this one I'm quite strict
about sometimes I do go over this rule
for example in this video but is to not
work in the evenings and that's because
I am a morning person in general so I
just don't work well in the evenings and
the evenings that I decide to work I
almost get nothing done and the next
morning I'm just super super tired and
also usually really stressed and I think
by having a really clear and quite
strict boundaries of what is my work
time and what is my own time you kind of
become way more productive during your
work time because as most of us know
work does fill the hours that we have so
if you allow yourself to work in the
evenings at least for me I kind of
notice that I start putting things off
to the evenings so during the day if I
have a really difficult assignment or I
have to make a presentation I'm usually
like I can do this in the evenings and I
started noticing that when I allowed
myself to do that during my PhD before I
knew it I was working like 14 16 hours a
day and this is not sustainable for
anyone so I would really recommend to
during the times that you notice that
you are in general not enjoying yourself
and you're not being productive to cut
those out of your work time to truly
assume that those are your downtime
hours so the fourth tip that for me
really really helped during the PHD is
to surround yourself with people that
have different values that are not
related to studying work productivity
all of these things so a lot of my
friends are family back at home they
kind of live their life very differently
and according to different values and I
think surrounding myself by these
friends they sometimes tell me how some
of the values I have or they reflect
back that some of the values that I have
are a little bit silly and then
sometimes if I work myself up to oh no
I'm not gonna do well for this
presentation and I'm gonna feel they
kind of tell me like don't worry calm
down this is not the end of the world
this is only your PhD and I think once
you're in a PhD it really feels like a
lot is dependent on it but if you have a
lot of friends outside of your PhD and
your studies they can kind of reflect
back on you that your PhD isn't that
important in the end and you're still a
complete whole person even outside of
your research or you're studying or your
work and the last thing and maybe this
is a little bit just related to me but
is to have hobbies that are
fundamentally unproductive because I
kind of noticed ever since I started a
YouTube channel and also a vlog on
Neuroscience I will link it down below
that even though I love making videos
and I love writing for my blog and I
love reading about Neuroscience I
noticed that almost all of my hobbies
had some kind of output and were in some
sense productive and thus really meant
that during no hour of the day I could
really truly turn off my brain like I
was always thinking of what is another
YouTube video I can make or what's
another blog post I can write or what's
my next research idea and even though I
truly love making YouTube videos and I
truly love doing research I did notice
that I just couldn't earn anything off
and I would always just be busy thinking
so something that I now try to do is the
things that I do in the weekend cannot
be in any sense related to anything
productive so for example things I enjoy
doing is playing games with friends
going out on long long walks through
nature listening to podcasts that are
just a bit silly and stupid and also
reading a lot of fantasy books which are
fundamentally unproductive like there's
no world where this will bring me any
type of benefit and I think this is just
really nice to have hobbies that are
just for you that are only truly for
your enjoyment and nothing else and
maybe this is just me but I sometimes
need to remind myself that it's okay to
just truly enjoy something just because
you enjoy it and not because it will get
you to some a final end goal and let me
know if you have any hobbies that are
truly unproductive because I love being
inspired and I love to read about what
other people enjoy without it having any
productive benefit and otherwise see you
next week bye